so now I get injuries andrew roberts we
put we put it together he helped me he's
has an excellent memory for dates better
than i we think it was in 2003 when i
add him and when I met him he gave a
talk at the travelers Club at a
Hillsdale College event over there and
Doug Jeffrey found him and I didn't know
who he was really and he started talking
and he was this brilliant young man and
the first thought I had was wow he's not
crazy highly educated you know Keyes
College Cambridge historian and he isn't
nuts and he's gone on to great strengths
he's written some important books he's
written the history of the
english-speaking people he's written two
books that qualify him for his most
recent book magnificently and one is he
wrote a biography of of Edward Halifax
Lord Irwin and then Lord Halifax who was
very important in the life of Winston
Churchill often opposed often in close
cooperation and so Andrew knows that
part you know Neville chant Edward
Halifax is the man who sat in the room
with Winston Churchill and Neville
Chamberlain when they decided who would
be prime minister in 1940 that's a
significant connection and Andrews
looked at all that from that side first
and then Andrew has written a book
called imminent true Chileans and it's a
it's modeled after 1923 I think it is
famous book called eminent Victorians
and it's all about the people who are in
the government and how they related to
each other and what they did but also
what they did in relation to each other
their Diaries and their letters and
their romances
sometimes not inside the sanctity of
matrimony
and so he put all that together and it's
it III come in the book too it's
dazzling and I and I remember as I was
reading it throughout saying how do you
find out all that stuff and then he had
this last great qualification to write
about Churchill who's half American and
that is his father was the franchisee of
Kentucky Fried Chicken in United Kingdom
and that means he understands that it
was between regular and extra-crispy now
you're ready to want to write about
Churchill it's so hard to write about
Churchill because he's you know it's
just there isn't anything like him
when I picked Churchill I was advised by
a great teacher pick some great person
in some great book and by the time
you're done and be able to say you know
as much about it as anybody alive and I
was so ignorant I didn't understand that
if you picked Churchill the volume in
comparison to say Lincoln or Washington
is just massively more and so you know
here are mine old man now having more or
less got through it but it's hard to do
that right and so to write a biography
of him to take all that and render it
into a microcosm which is what has got
to be the book is a thousand pages long
and I promise you'll enjoy every page of
it it's fun it's you know Churchill was
exciting Hitler is exciting and that's
how Hitler
history is exciting Hitler is exciting
why did I think I was about to say what
about but it is true
Hitler is exciting and therefore the
fella who was responsible more than any
other fellow for his downfall is
exciting and those are great traumatic
turning points event events that stand
important in the whole history of the
human race and how do you take all that
about a man who wrote 50 books of his
own
roughly and render it into some kind of
coherence and not lose the fun of it
almost no one has ever done that I would
say no one except that I used to work
for Martin Gilbert didn't have a great
loyalty to him but Andrew Roberts has
done that bless him for it
ladies and gentlemen it's a great honor
to be invited to address you and thank
you very much indeed Larry for those
tremendously kind words and it's so
wonderful see quite so many people here
as well I once gave a speech at the
Sevenoaks literary festival in Kent
where fewer people turned up than there
were oaks when when Larry invited me to
to speak about the importance of Winston
Churchill today it was six months ago
and I don't think that even he could
have spotted his own preference because
in the last week or two weeks in fact
Winston Churchill has been turned into a
political football in my country and the
deputy leader of the Labour Party John
MacDonald who has always prided himself
on his on his Marxism Leninism has acqui
accused instant Churchill of being a
villain and one can imagine therefore
the the response quite a very pleased to
say most of it negative but
unfortunately some people including
Mayor Sadiq Khan of the Mayor of London
as has generally come out also highly
critical of Churchill the week before
that we had a 24-year old green MP from
the Scottish Parliament called Winston
Churchill a war criminal and a war
monger why anybody was expecting any
sense from a 24-year old green member of
the Scottish Parliament anyhow I know
it's ah but nonetheless and and in your
country a little little over two months
ago the astronaut scott kelly who is of
course the UN ambassador to space
only the United Nations ladies and
gentlemen would want to have an
ambassador somewhere that has no people
and no government said that Churchill
was also a I think that the phrase was
was a racist war monger he didn't bother
to educate himself he didn't bother to
read any any books about Churchill or or
to learn about Churchill learn the truth
at all he just came out with that remark
I really do feel that the spaceil to
concentrating is the one between his
ears so I think it's worthwhile just to
go back just to remind ourselves why
Winston Churchill does in fact still
have contemporary relevant relevance
today why he is important today and it's
not because of course of the actual
battles that he fought in British
domestic politics frankly what happened
in the tony pandey riot what happened in
the with the Black and Tans what
happened with the gold standard or the
abdication crisis or even the even the
Dardanelles expedition those are a
hundred years old they are all in the
past they are all long dead and buried
however the reason that he still matters
today is because of the truths that he
told because of the leadership that he
showed because of the personality that
he was and above all because of the
foresight that he showed the qualities
that we still need in leaders just as
much today as ever we have done in the
past because of the elegance that he
used to to make people listen to him who
didn't want to and who didn't agree with
him and because of the moral and indeed
the physical courage that he showed as
well these are qualities ladies and
gentlemen and of course Winston
Churchill himself said of courage that
it was
rightly esteemed the first of all the
qualities because it guarantees all the
others and these are the qualities
therefore that we have every right still
to in a democracy to look for in our
leaders and which therefore are just as
important as ever they were before and
perhaps more important now today than
ever before I'd like to take you back to
the evening of Friday the 10th of May
1940 when Winston Churchill was made
prime minister by King George the 6th at
Buckingham Palace and he of course and
it was a it was the evening of the same
day that Adolf Hitler had unleashed
blitzkrieg on the West invading Holland
and Belgium and Luxembourg
shortly afterwards of course also to
invade France and it was of that day
that Winston Churchill famously wrote in
his in his first volume the gathering
storm of his autobiography of his of his
war memoirs should I say I felt as if I
were walking with destiny and that all
my past life would been but a pressure
preparation for this hour and for this
trial and this was so true all of his
past life the speeches that now cover
8,000 pages the jobs that he had as
First Lord of the Admiralty of course
before the First World War and and
during the First World War and in the
Second World War the being Chancellor of
the Exchequer and Home Secretary and
minister of munitions in charge of two
and a half million people in the
munitions factories these were indeed a
preparation for his hour and his trial
but what I also try to do in my book is
to look at the beginning part of that
sentence the bit about walking with
destiny because there too you see
something which is important for for
Churchill and the way that we should
look at him today because it is
impossible to understand
Churchill ladies and gentlemen unless
you understand that he also had this
sense this driving sense of personal
destiny
he was 16 years old when he told his
best friend at Harrow
Winston Churchill was almost entirely
self educated owing to the fact that he
had to be because he went to Harrow that
there were going to be terrible
struggles great upheavals in his life
and in both of their lives in the life
of the nation and that he was going to
be called upon to save England and to
save London and he said that at the age
of 16 and everything that happened to
him after that all the close brushes
with death that he had the many close
brushes with death underpin the sense of
personal destiny and so when he was born
prematurely two months prematurely a
close brush with death in late Victorian
England when he was stabbed at the age
of 10 years old in the stomach by a
school friend clearly not a very close
friend when he nearly died at the age of
11 when he when he nearly died of
pneumonia on which occasion by the way
the doctors administered brandy to the
eleven-year-old and both orally and
rectally which he would have thought
might have put you off brandy for life
but didn't in Winston Churchill's gaze
he was he was only a little bit older
when he survived a near drowning on Lake
Geneva he survived a house fire that
burnt down the stately home that he was
sleeping in at three o'clock in the
morning he was involved in two plane
crashes three car crashes in on the
front of my book there is the wonderful
Joseph Karsch
photograph of him in 1941 and you could
see this huge scar down the center of
his of his head and his forehead and
that came as a result of him trying to
cross the road in Fifth Avenue in New
York and being an Englishman looking in
the wrong direction
and those by the way ladies and
gentlemen are only the peacetime clothes
brushes with death in wartime he also
took part in the greatest cavalry charge
of being of the British Empire at the
Battle of Omdurman where no fewer than
25% of his regiment the 21st Lancers
were either killed or wounded and then
the following year his armored train was
attacked by the Boers in the South
African War and on that occasion 34
percent of his unit were killed or
wounded and then two months later he
escaped from a prisoner of war camp and
crossed 300 miles of enemy territory at
one point he hid down a mineshaft and
when the candle guttered out he could
feel rats scurrying over his face and
then in the First World War he entered
no man land no man's land
no fewer than thirty times now he didn't
need to he was lieutenant the colonel of
the 6th battalion of the Royal Scots
Fusiliers he could have stayed back at
battalion headquarters if he'd wanted to
but he didn't because he never believed
that he should ever ask anybody in his
regiment to do anything he wasn't
willing personally to do himself and so
he got so close to the German trenches
he could actually hear them speaking in
their trenches and then on one occasion
of course he left his dugout in the
front line and five minutes after he
left left it a German whiz-bang
high-explosive came and decapitated
everybody in the dugout and on that
occasion he said that he felt as if he
could hear the beating of invisible
wings over him invisible wings obviously
taking care of him ensuring that he was
going to survive in order to save London
and to save England when you look
actually at theologically at his belief
in the Almighty he did believe in the
Almighty when you look into his belief
in the Almighty
it seems primarily to is the duty of the
Almighty was to take care of Winston
Churchill
the what this gave him what this is
extraordinary sense of personal destiny
gave him was a calmness an amazing
calmness in the greatests and most
terrifying most perilous moments of my
country's history and he was able to
make jokes in the House of Commons when
he was being attacked during a
confidence motion so theoretically the
entire government was at stake and he
made a joke when he was being attacked
on the completely useless a 22 tank and
he said that when the defects and the
teething troubles of the a 22 tank were
apparent to all it was appropriately
rechristened the Churchill and the
keyword in that of course is
appropriately because Winston Churchill
knew but he had teething troubles and
defects he had got so many things wrong
he'd got women's suffrage wrong he got
the gold-standard wrong he got the
abdication crisis wrong primarily of
course he had got the Dardanelles
expedition wrong a brilliant concept an
absolutely brilliant idea to get the
Royal Navy from the eastern
Mediterranean through the Dardanelles
straits into the Sea of Marmara and to
have anchored it off Istanbul then
called Constantinople and by the threat
of shelling to have taken the Ottoman
Empire out of the Central Powers in the
First World War
had it come off ladies and gentlemen it
would have been one of the greatest coos
in the history of warfare as it happened
because of the implementation of it not
by him but by the Admirals he was back
in London we actually lost the Allies
lost six ships on that day the 18th of
March 1915 and then it was that the the
they doubled down on the on the defeat
as it were and undertook a huge invasion
and fibia so salt on the Gallipoli
Peninsula on the western side of the
Straits which was ultimately over the
next eight months to cost the Allies a
hundred and forty-seven thousand
and wounded and this was entirely blamed
on Winston Churchill even though he was
not the only person in favor of it but
he was certainly the primary scapegoat
of it people shouted at him what about
the Dardanelles well into the 1930s but
one of the wonderful things about
Winston Churchill and one of the reasons
that he is so relevant still today is
that he learned from his mistakes he
learned from each of his mistakes the
the lesson he learned of course from the
Dardanelles was never to overrule the
chiefs of staff during the Second World
War if all three of the chiefs of staff
agreed on something he did not overrule
them even though he had every
constitutional right to do so
he was the Minister of Defense as well
as the Prime Minister and so you have
therefore somebody who a politician who
learns from his mistakes he didn't have
an early an easy childhood his father
the aloof disdainful mercurial but
brilliant Chancellor of the Exchequer
Lord Randolph Churchill was somebody who
never spotted any brilliance in his son
and was and was harsh to him in fact in
my book there there are letters that he
wrote to his son that no father should
ever write to any son and yet Winston
Churchill especially when his father
died at the age of 45 when Churchill was
20 he he adored his father he wrote his
father's two-volume biography he was
able to name his son Randolph he quoted
his father endlessly in speeches he
sought out his father's friends he
adopted his father's political views the
Tory democracy of Benjamin Disraeli in
1947 he actually believed that he'd met
his father's ghost and they talked and
in the course of their long conversation
he never let on to his father that he
had been instrumental in helping win the
Second World War
so you can see in that a a sense that
Winston Churchill's career was bound up
with attempting to impress the shade of
his long dead father
his mother too was was almost unamerican
in the way that she said born of course
in in Brooklyn but almost an American in
the way that she showed no interest in
her son and in 1884 in the first six
months of 1884 when Churchill was nine
years old she only saw him for about six
and a half hours and there to Churchill
refused to allow that to be a
debilitating factor in his life just
like with his relationship with his
father and he loved his mother and he
said in the in my early life his
autobiography that she shone for me like
the evening star brilliant but at a
distance he was almost entirely broke
all his life this was partly his own
fault of course partly because his
parents were spendthrift but also
because he was always satisfied as his
friend great friend Fe Smith said with
the best of everything and he and but
when he he for the first moment in his
life that he ever made any money when he
was in his early seventies and the thing
he did and this was of course as a
result of signing the contract to his to
his war memoirs the first thing he did
was to buy the first of 37 racehorses
which he and and he put his his jockeys
into his father's racing colors and the
key thing to remember I think in all of
this is that he was not therefore to be
seen you should never see Winston
Churchill as the buttons up
victorian-era Socrative his age and
class and background he was not that he
was instead a throwback to an earlier
era he was a Regency figure a romantic
figure somebody he was willing to wear
his heart on his sleeve in the course of
the Second World War there were no fewer
than 50 opportunities for sorry 50 times
when he burst into tears in public
50 I sometimes think that it's a reason
may who by the way has every right to
burst into tears were to were to burst
into tears in public how on earth that
would that would affect us but with
Churchill people didn't mind because
they recognized that he was a he was a
different kind of figure and a true
Regency figure I don't believe for a
moment that he was a depressive as has
been made out he chaired the Defence
Committee of the War Cabinet no fewer
than a thousand times during the Second
World War it is a depression is a
debilitating illness but the only time
that he ever used the phrase Black Dog
it was in July 1911 when he was writing
to his wife Clementine at a time when
that phrase was used by Edwardian
matrons and governesses to explain their
ill-tempered children I don't believe
that he had that or indeed manic
depression or as I've seen in some in
some biographies bipolar disease neither
do I think that he was an alcoholic
he certainly drank an enormous amount
there's no doubt about that but he had
this iron Constitution for alcohol only
once in the whole 2194 days of the
Second World War was Churchill drunk and
in a meeting that went on until 3
o'clock in the morning on the 7th of
March 1944 and on 1 on that occasion
what they did was to just hold the
meeting again the next morning
pretending that the last one hadn't
happened
his friend CP Scott said of said of
Churchill that Winston Churchill
couldn't have been an alcoholic because
no alcoholic could have drunk that much
there was a wonderful moment where after
the war and indeed after his in after
his retirement Churchill used to invite
people to chart all to come and see the
library in the study and the and the
drawing-room they get to the drawing
room at the end and Churchill would
invite his guests to have a drink and to
American Mormons were invited and he
invited them to have a drink and one of
them said to him strong drink rejith and
stingeth like a serpent and Winston
Churchill replied I've long been looking
for a drink like that
[Laughter]
so huh so how was it how was it ladies
and gentlemen that he was the person and
this goes back again to the kind of
leadership that that is just as relevant
today as ever it was before how was it
that he was able to show such
extraordinary foresight not just
foresight before the second world war
which we all know about the the
foresight to spot Hitler and the Nazis
for what they were but also before the
First World War when he was able to spot
Prussian militarism for the danger it
posed and also after the Second World
War when his in his great speech in the
the iron curtain speech in Fulton
Missouri in March 1946 he also warned
the world about Stalin and the threats
of Soviet imperialism to Eastern Europe
I think it comes very much from three
things especially the with regard to
Hitler and the Nazis the first was that
he was a file OSI might he liked Jews he
admired them he had marred them for
their contribution to the ethics of
Western civilization he'd grown up with
him his father had like Jews he'd been
on holiday with him he represented them
in his in one of his constituencies and
he therefore had an early warning system
that was not vouchsafed to many of the
other people of his age and class and
background on the conservative benches
many of whom were anti-semitic the
second thing was that he was in
historian one of the reasons that I'm
proud to be an historian is that Winston
Churchill was one and he was able to put
the threat made by the Nazis and Hitler
into the long continuum of British
history the dangers the hegemonist ik
threat to the balance of power in Europe
was something that we had seen before
and he knew that we'd seen it with
philip ii of spain and the spanish
armada we'd seen it with louis xiv of
france and the war of austrian
succession which of course his own great
ancestor John Churchill first you could
more Brown had been instrumental in
defeating we'd seen it with Napoleon who
he admired for his ambition and he
maude for his sense of destiny but who
he also appreciated closed-in hegemonist
ik threat and then of course the Kaiser
who had fought against himself and then
Hitler and the third thing ladies and
gentlemen is that he had seen fanaticism
in his life he had come up close and
personal to the kind of fanaticism on
the northwest frontier in India and in
the Sudan which was of course in this
case religious Islamic fundamentalist
fanaticism but was the same thing as the
religious fanaticism of the Nazis in so
many ways and that also was not
something that had ever affected people
like the prime ministers of the 1930s
like Ramsay MacDonald and Stanley
Baldwin and Neville Chamberlain they had
never seen fanaticism in their life and
so you have these things together the
three things together coming together
and and allowing Winston Churchill to
have this extraordinary prescience and
he also because he had this prescience
and because he had this background and
because he have this self belief and
this sense of of destiny he also was
able to ignore opinion polls to not hire
a spin doctor or a speech writer in his
life to take no notice of focus groups
to actually what you got from Winston
Churchill you knew you had straight from
him and on top of all of these things
the ability to learn from his mistakes
this extraordinary physical courage a
moral courage also that he was able to
be shouted down in the House of Commons
his seat nearly taken away from him by
the Conservative Party after the Munich
Agreement lambasted and attacked and
ridiculed by the press and he did not
change his message his message that we
needed to rearm especially in the air
and that that kind of leadership
ladies and gentlemen needed only one
more
in order to make it unbelievably
powerful and that was of course his
eloquence and he got his eloquence by
hard work by practice by reading
McCauley and reading Gibbon and knowing
Shakespeare back to France his
marvellous moments in the Second World
War where he has a competition with
Field Marshal Smuts about who knows
Shakespeare them all and after about a
quarter of an hour
Smart's had to give up and then a little
bit later on he realized that actually
Churchill was making it up yeah can you
imagine try to make up them I am big
pant amateurs but because of this
extraordinary work that he had put into
it work he had put into it when his
brother officers were relaxing in the
heat of the of the of the Sun in in
India at Bangalore in the late 1890s but
he was reading reading reading he
managed therefore to create phrases that
will live as long as our tongue survives
he was once asked during the war by his
private secretary how it was what were
the tricks of the trade what were the
techniques that you use in order to
create these extraordinary
morale-boosting speeches he said well
there were four things the first was
that each sentence needs to convey one
idea and one idea only don't be bogged
down with sub clauses and so on what he
called that noble thing the English
sentence and the second thing was
therefore keep sentences as short as
possible keep words as long as possible
if you're not attempting to to show off
that you know a long word use the right
word and it's often the shortest word
and also he said try and use anglo-saxon
words Old English words words that the
english-speaking peoples feel
comfortable with and know instinctively
because they've been using them for a
thousand years and if you therefore look
at the peroration that
paragraph of the great we shall fight on
the beaches speech of the 4th of June
1940 about when he was telling the
British people what they were going to
do when the paratroopers started landing
and when the ship started landing in
southern England and he told the British
people that they were going to fight on
the beaches and the landing Graff
landing grounds and in the hills and the
streets and fight with growing
confidence in the air and that they were
never going to surrender when you look
at that peroration paragraph of a
hundred and forty-one words all but two
of them are in Old English they are they
come from the dictionary of Old English
the only two exceptions being the word
confidence which comes from the Latin
and surrender which comes from the
French
you you did ask an Englishman here
ladies and gentlemen
so to say to conclude a man of
extraordinary physical courage and
indeed that didn't stop of course in the
Second World War either he traveled
Winston Churchill traveled a hundred and
ten thousand miles outside the United
Kingdom as Prime Minister he was the
person who therefore and think of that
travel it was often in unpressurized
cabins he was in his early seventies
very often it was within the radius of
the Luftwaffe when he came back from the
United States on one occasion his plane
was struck by lightning had the
instrumentation gone down so would he
have and when he took ships it was
across u-boat infested oceans the sheer
the sheer courage of that and of course
it was necessary because he was the glue
that kept the big three together
President Roosevelt of course was
profoundly disabled he was still able to
to leave the Europe the American
continent three times during the war
Marshall Stalin did not enjoy flying he
didn't like flying he was a bit scared
of flying he stayed he only left the
Soviet Union once during the Second
World War and so it took Winston
Churchill to visit Moscow twice to visit
the Washington several times Quebec and
so on
Cairo Casablanca the the the sheer
amount of time that he spent traveling
showed in tremendous guts on his part
and of course he was ill he had a minor
heart flutter in the in the White House
when he was staying for three weeks
after Pearl Harbor in the White House he
had several bouts of pneumonia on one
occasion in my in May 1943 in Carthage a
doctor came to him and asked him for
some blood for a testing and Churchill
said yes well you can take some from my
or my finger and I also have an almost
infinite expanse of arse so there you
have just to conclude a man of
extraordinary courage both physical and
moral a man of the capacity for
foresight that in my view puts all of
the all of the other mistakes he made
the trivial mistake they make they make
all of those mistakes trivial but he was
somebody who could learn from his
mistakes and did and then also that on
top of everything else that eloquence
and as a result therefore ladies and
gentlemen you have somebody who was able
to go beyond even what he heard
predicted and prescribed for himself as
a 16 year old school boy because he was
not just able to save London and England
he also saved civilization itself thank
you very much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much dr. Roberts we do have time
for some questions I should mention that
Andrew will be signing copies of his New
York Times best seller Churchill walking
with destiny right after this Q&A
session out in the out in the lobby but
we do have some time for some questions
now from the audience we have
microphones with students or students
with microphones students bringing the
microphones around please wait for a
microphone and thank you very much for
your speech enjoyed it I enjoyed I
didn't read your book I downloaded it
audibly listen to it that's much better
by the way your nature is very good and
I like the voice that he had for Winston
itself so you could tell well tell the
accent that's for you so there's all
kinds of questions that I have a little
tiny one and that is Halifax during that
meeting in May he said he didn't want to
be Prime Minister but then there's the
theory that he really wanted Winston to
take it and he knew he would sign the
peace agreement with Churchill and then
he would become Israel troops to that
and I go into this in in a great deal of
detail deliberately in this book because
there are so many different sources
about this and they don't all agree and
I think that Winston Churchill's own own
memory of this where he gets the day
wrong and the time wrong for this and
also sort of claims that the Premiership
fell into his lap through a long silence
that that he claims took place it
doesn't ring true for me at all and I
think some of the other other sources
make it a little bit more clear that
what Winston Churchill actually did on
the
at 4:30 in the afternoon on Thursday the
9th of May 1940 was to do what he had
always done in his career which was to
to ask for the office that he took and
he knew the crisis
he knew the he'd been waiting for this
for 40 years anyway he'd wanted the
Premiership all his life and this was
going to be his great moment and the
idea that he sat back and waited it to
fall into his lap just doesn't ring true
to me at all I think he I think he
demanded it and and he had every right
to because he was the only person who
had been proved right about Adolf Hitler
over the previous 10 years and all
Halifax and certainly David Morrison
somebody else who's in this room who was
the Chief Whip and Neville Chamberlain
himself of course had all been proved
wrong and so I'd be interested to hear
what you and other readers feel about my
chapter 19 which for me is the is the is
really the key one I think that that's
what happened
I was asked a question which is not
involved huge political churchill but
one of the paragraphs in your early
chapters which i have read the whole
book said English imperialism in India
was wrong and then you said Churchill
believed that England had brought raros
rose but most importantly and uncorrupt
judicial system a administration that
was work and ended sati and you had a
whole paragraph of things that Churchill
thought were good for India and there's
that paragraph you said but of course
imperialism was wrong and I thought that
was satire
I just curious was that your point or
not there really ought to be a special
fund for irony
next question
over on this side dr. Roberts on this
side yes sir
there was a whimsical story I heard once
when Winston was visiting the White
House I'd like you to debunk it if you
might that mr. Churchill had a habit at
times of not wearing a stitch of
clothing and that the president walked
in on him and Winston without skipping a
beat said let it be known that the Prime
Minister of Great Britain has nothing to
hide from the President of the United
States would you confirm or deny that
sir
absolutely confirm it it comes from
Patrick Fowler and the queue was one of
Churchill's secretaries and it's very
much in the Canon yes it did happen when
he was turned out of office how did he
handle that and we've heard it was war
weariness on a part of the British
people but it was a turn towards
socialism and how long was he in a funk
about that oh do you mean Lee snap out
of it and Winston Churchill was never in
a funk about anything he he snapped out
of it immediately the defeat in the 1945
general election on the 26th of July
came as a surprise to him because he had
been treated by huge crowds with with
great enthusiasm all the way through the
general election especially the crowds
in the Midlands and in the north and he
had a terrible shock on the day if there
had been a presidential system he would
undoubtedly have won that election but
of course we have a parliamentary one
and he was only one person one name on
650 ballots and the Conservative Party
was going to be punished for appeasement
and many people also did want the
what they thought of as the New
Jerusalem of socialism the welfare state
the National Health Service all the
things that they thought were going to
come an awful lot cheaper than they
ultimately did and when Clementine
Churchill's wife said to him on that day
as the results were coming in and it was
clear there was a landslide against him
that it might be a blessing in disguise
Winston Churchill replied well from
where I'm sitting it seems quite
effectively disguised question has to be
asked though on whether or not it was a
blessing in disguise because ultimately
Churchill was exhausted by the end of
the war the kind of things that he would
have needed to have dealt with with
regard to austerity and the end of
empire and so on were not things that he
was excited or interested about and and
he was able to recharge his batteries
over the following six years he went on
painting holidays to Lake Como and
France and Marrakesh and elsewhere and
by the end of it he was able to come
back and win the 1951 general election
which considering the massive defeat
that he'd experienced in 1945 was an
extraordinary achievement so maybe
actually Clementine was right and it was
indeed a blessing in disguise although
not for the British people I hasten to
add because we've still got the National
Health Service to this day and it is a
it is an appalling incubus
thank you for your speech tonight
considering the environment we find
ourselves in today with all the talking
heads out there willing to give their
insight and wisdom including former
presidents knowing Winston Churchill as
well as you do what do you think he
would say to Donald Trump in his battle
against his own party entrenched deep
state and those people who really just
aren't supportive of him what do you
think he would say today I think that's
search well first of all Mary Soames
Churchill's daughter always used to say
to me and others never assume that you
know what papar would have said under
any circumstances especially in art half
a century after his death I think it
would have been very difficult with them
Churchill in modern day politics
although but not least because he smoked
160,000 cigars and you know drank a good
deal and and other things that would
have worked against him as a modern-day
politician
with regard to and that's a British
politician let alone an American one
nonetheless I think he was very very
good at using all the latest technology
I think he'd have been brilliant on
Twitter for example he he was so good
many of his great reposts would have
fitted in perfectly to 280 characters or
fewer there was a time when he was
giving a speech and and someone shouted
rot at him and and he replied I'd like
to thank the Honourable member for
telling us what's in his mind
that certainly would have fitted into
280 characters question 4 over here is
that sorry I thought I said what okay Oh
Sir Winston Churchill as well as
Theodore Roosevelt I mean the theater as
a Franklin Roosevelt and many other
great leaders have come from the higher
echelon of society privileged in their
upbringing but of course we have the
Toccata me of abraham lincoln who came
from the lowest level what do you think
is the inspiration or the cause of such
leadership
it's obviously not based on upbringing
it must be based on some other element
that makes them so great yes that's a
very good question certainly not
upbringing and or indeed social class
every Winston Churchill was an
aristocrat he was born in a palace and
not just any old palace a palace that
the Royals envied he was the grandson of
a Duke of course and he had this this
sense of noblesse oblige now today I'm
afraid he would be attacked as as having
a sense of entitlement but actually the
kind of entitlement that he had was the
best possible kind the idea that you you
had privileges in life but it was your
duty to spend your entire life returning
to the to the to the people the energies
that you had in your in your existence
and so it was something that was
tremendously powerful not just in
British politics but of course he
extended it also to the Empire and and
believed that that was a sacred trust
that needed to to take the the lives and
the and the energies and the effort of
millions of Britons and I think
therefore actually there is something
very
model if it could be properly harnessed
in that kind of attitude towards life
and it doesn't it doesn't in any way
have to come from a particular class
whatsoever but I do think that it would
be a shame if we were to basically cut
out from politics anyone who's had a
privileged upbringing because of this
ghastly sense of the opposite of envy
and because Envy is the most barren of
all the vices and it's something that
socialism builds on and taken and and
sucks out and and and makes it really
makes people feel that just because
somebody's had a privileged background
that they have nothing to contribute and
yet the the great Renaissance men of
history and women of history have have
not come from any particular social
class at all so I'm I think I'm with you
in what I suspect is your is your
question I think that it's a it's a
terrible new idea this idea of somebody
being so entitled that they can't
contribute to society of course they can
and they must
[Applause]
[Music]
got a couple more questions and then I'm
going to end with the Churchill Jake if
that's all right gentlemen here two
questions are related did Churchill have
friends and secondly did he live a
lonely life as busy as it was um he he
had lots of friends he had lots of great
friends he was a man who had a special
special talent indeed I would argue a
genius for friendship when one looks at
the relationships we that he had with
people like Professor Linderman or Effie
Smith or Brendan Bracken or most of the
members of the club that he set up off
his friends called the other Club one
realizes that he was a man who had a
tremendous capacity for friendship and
this came from several areas first of
all his wonderful sense of humor of
course which which was which was
gigantic also his belief in sticking by
his friends even if it's even if it hurt
him politically he was he was willing to
so long as they behaved honorably of
course he would he would put up with any
any amount of bad behavior from his
friends frankly there's a there's a rule
in the other Club which states that that
nothing shall in no rule nothing in this
club will interfere with the asperity
and rancor of party politics and so he
was able to take to make friends from
outside his own political party which
was very lucky considering you changed
his party twice famously saying that
anyone can rat but it takes a certain
ingenuity to rear at and and so yes no
he did wick was he'll only I don't
believe he was only for a moment no he
he'd been partly because of his friends
and partly also because of his his wife
Clementine Hugh who was his rock and he
he really he was fascinated of course by
politics and and could always pick up
the phone to anybody that he wanted to
he was a man who was capable of being on
his own and that was a good thing too
because he wrote as as Larry said he
wrote the best part of 50 books 980
articles he was he was somebody who
needed to be on his own in order to work
but he was he was capable of being alone
but not lonely and I think that's one of
the great attributes in life we have
time for one more question
after a World War two we saw the sense
of Englishness and the duty of the
Englishman declined we saw the Empire
decline was that a material thing was
that a cultural thing was that a lack of
leadership that someone like Churchill
might have been able to change had he
been a younger man at that time or was
it just the the sunset of an empire
after an exhausting series of world wars
I think it was the I think it's very
much the last of those although
culturally of course socialism had did
suck the lifeblood out of the empire as
well because the Atlee government wanted
to to be rid of India nonetheless by the
end of the Second World War
maybe we could have survived one world
war but to to you know within a quarter
of a century it was asking too much of
anyone and yet if an empire if the great
a great empire an empire on which a
quarter of the which-which at one stage
had about of covered about a fifth of
the world land surface was ever going to
to decline and die as as our state as
the British Empire did in what better
what more noble cause could it possibly
die than in the defeat of Nazism if it
had to go that was the way to go an
honorable way to go I think
ladies and gentlemen just one one
Churchill gag that I'd like him to tell
you
my favorite Churchill gag oh is changes
from times they're about 200 Churchill
jokes in this book and so obviously they
they change from points from time to
time but the one that I particularly
love at the moment is the moment when
his private secretary came to him in the
early 1950s and told him that their cook
had been made pregnant as the result of
the nocturnal assignation with a man in
the street in Verona and Winston
Churchill immediately replied obviously
not one of the two gentlemen thank you
very much indeed
[Applause]